i feel like my biggest mistake always is
going into things very optimistic no
this is so much harder than i thought it
would be
hey it's hannah and if you're wondering
why i'm standing outside with a giant
walk in somebody's backyard it's because
my boys and i have been playing a lot of
zelda breath of the wild my favorite
thing to do is cook so as link you can
cook all sorts of foods like soups and
stews and desserts even mushroom risotto
over an open flame and since i love
cooking so much in the game it got me
wondering could i actually make one of
the dishes over an open flame in real
life so today that's exactly what i'm
going to do i'm going to see if i can
make mushroom risotto like breath of the
wild and luckily my friend andrew from
binging with babish has already
attempted this and he filmed some
pointers for me hey hannah andrew ray
here from binging with babish and i hear
that you're making the risotto from
zelda breath of the wild and having made
that once before i just wanted to give
you a little advice first off don't be
afraid to take it off the fire you know
open fire very hard to regulate so if it
starts scorching or burning just take it
off put it back on second make sure that
pan is super duper well seasoned
otherwise it's gonna stick and third
make sure you wear a short sleeve of
everything because it gets
extraordinarily hot to get a spritz
bottle to spritz yourself down with good
luck hats off hope it comes out for you
short sleeve shirt check spritz bottle
check now it's time to get started so in
the game link travels all over the land
foraging for food all over the place
luckily i have a grocery store and so
i'm just going to get my ingredients
from the kitchen not everything that
link uses exists in the real world but i
tried to get as close as i could so this
is what i'll be using shiitake mushrooms
for the hillian shroom kosher salt for
the rock salt arborio rice for the
helium rice and butter so that's all
that link uses but i want my risotto to
be pretty tasty so i'll be adding
chicken stock olive oil shallots garlic
cloves thyme pepper white wine and
grated parmesan cheese now in the game
link just walks up to a cauldron on a
fire pit lights it throws the
ingredients in and in like two seconds
risotto
now i have a cauldron i have a fire pit
but i really don't think it's going to
take a few seconds to make i think it's
going to be a bit more of a laborious
process let's get into it it's time to
start cooking i got my wok i got my fire
pit it's nice and smoky and so i'm going
to start by adding plenty of olive oil
just like andrew said and make sure that
my pan is really seasoned that's a lot
but i'm gonna wipe it up
sorry it's making my eyes water what the
heck i feel like i need goggles and like
a gas mask he just chills and sits right
by the fire and is like anyway now my
food is done i have barely even started
and i'm like oh this is hard okay so i
am spreading the olive oil around the
wok with my paper towel so that it gets
nice and seasoned and nothing sticks to
the side because that is not what i want
but as a result i'm crying
so there's that
so now that i've had a good cry it's
time for me to back up a little bit i
have this lovely tennis racket that i'm
gonna be
mixing the risotto with it's nice and
far so that i don't have to hover over
the flame too much and i'm going to add
my shallots so i want these shallots to
look a little translucent now i'm
actually having a nice smoke-free moment
i don't want to jinx myself but this is
going swimmingly
probably 90 degrees out today so i
figured why not go outside over a hot
fire and cook i really enjoy overheating
time for the butter got all these
shiitake mushrooms i need a lot because
look how big this wok is oh
sizzle sizzle sizzle this smells
delicious
now let's get these
mushrooms
so i'm holding my paddle between my
knees and i'm going to add my shiitake
mushrooms there's a big old trickle of
back sweat heading downtown link has got
to sweat when he's doing this he is
sweating as much as i am if not more
that's nice all right so i moved a
little bit out of the smoke i got my fan
to like blast it away if i need to and
now i'm feeling so much more powerful to
be honest i feel like i just ate a new
heart so these mushrooms are softening
up nicely can you believe that this is
over an open flame so now it's time to
add some minced garlic here some thyme
i'm going to sprinkle on a little salt
then some fresh ground pepper that's a
well-seasoned risotto okay let's mix
this up the more area you get with the
food the quicker it's cooking i'm
realizing when i have it in a pile in
the center it's really not cooking the
top it's getting very warm and i'm
getting a little tired this really is
the only thing keeping me going right
now this is smelling really fragrant so
let's dump in our rice and then this is
gonna get nice and toasty we're gonna
coat it in the mushroom shallot butter
mixture and get it toasty for a couple
minutes don't come back stay over there
all right rice is toasty and now it's
time to drink a bottle of wine i like to
do a white wine in mushroom risotto it
just tastes really good and it all
evaporates and the alcohol cooks off
okay i'm having a rough time okay i'm
having a hard day when i get home tell
my husband it was a hard day at the
office okay again want to make sure i
spread it around so that i get a lot of
cooking
surface area then once this is
evaporated it's time to add the stock
that wine evaporated very quickly look
at that now you want to add the broth a
little bit at a time in roto make sure
it's fully absorbed you don't want to
overload it with broth because then you
could get kind of a gluey mixture so you
want it to fully absorb a little at a
time and then get that fully integrated
into the rice so i have been doing this
for about an hour adding stock and
letting it absorb and i think we're
getting there we're in the home stretch
all right it's parmesan time this is
looking like it's about ready to serve
so let's try this
i'm honestly feeling a little nervous
that it's just not gonna taste right i
haven't been able to taste it at all
through these steps because it's just
really difficult over this campfire so
i'm nervous that all of this work will
go to waste if it tastes really gross it
smells good it smells a little smoky but
i know it won't taste smoky so that's
good all that's left here is for me to
plate this i'm gonna garnish it and
plate it the way it looks in the game
with a little mushroom on top and i
think it's basil so i think it'll taste
good all right it's the moment of truth
i'm nervous to try it i almost just want
to leave it and not eat it because then
i won't have failed all right one two
three
[Music]
oh my gosh this is really good wow the
shiitake mushrooms are really good in
risotto it's creamy it's cheesy the rice
is pretty evenly cooked i'm shocked like
i was expecting some chunks of raw rice
in here it took two seconds in the game
today it took two hours so is it
delicious yes is it worth the time
yes because i got this sweet t-shirt out
of it and now i can say that i did it
win-win it's much harder than the video
game makes it seem of course but i had a
really fun time trying it out and the
finished product is delicious so thanks
for watching let us know if there are
any other video game foods you want us
to try to make irl and i will see you
next time
oh yes i'm gonna eat this whole bowl
this is really good
[Music]
you